the last institution to have held out
against leftist ideology
has succumbed for decades the left
has hollowed out the media the schools
the churches the corporations
and now even the u.s military has gone
woke
as the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
frets about the supposed scourge
of white rage
sure first of all on the
issue of critical race theory etc i'll
obviously have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is um but i do think
it's important
actually for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
uh and i i want to understand white rage
and i'm white
and i want to understand it so what is
it that caused
thousands of people to assault this
building
and try to overturn the constitution of
the united states of america what caused
that
i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to analyze it
it's important that we understand that
i've read miles seitan i've read i've
read karl marx
i've read lenin that doesn't make me a
communist so what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we are here to defend
few things stir up my own swarthy rage
quite like hearing the chairman of the
joint chiefs use phrases
such as white rage but as parents
of all races across the country stand up
against critical race theory
transgenderism other aspects of leftist
ideology
the establishment is doing its damnedest
both to deny
and to defend their kooky agenda i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from old schooled
who says if you were trying to
confiscate citizens guns
while simultaneously telling them they
would need an f-15 or
nukes to defend themselves against the
government you
just might be a tyrant well you're
you're certainly proving the point of
the second amendment
i would say if you're if your main
argument
as joe biden's is right now for
undermining your civil right to
a gun is that the government's gonna
nuke you
if you if you push back uh then i think
really you are
undercutting the idea that people should
give up their guns doesn't make a lot of
sense people need to be able
to help themselves if you want to help
yourself fix your car by the way i would
strongly recommend
rock auto rockauto.com has a catalog
that is so simple
i can navigate it it has prices that are
so reliable i don't need to worry about
the gimmicks of buying on tuesday
morning or wednesday afternoon or
anything like that
and it has every single part that you
need for your car or truck that's it
and best of all in my view it's not
going to
pester you with a thousand questions and
degrade and humiliate you and then not
have the part like when you go into the
brick and mortar store you know you go
in there
they got a million questions about
whether your core is the gx or the px or
whatever
you know p90x i don't know what kind of
car and then they go into the back of
the store and they don't have any of the
parts and then they order it online
probably from rock auto and they charge
you twice as much don't do that
don't do that you can skip that whole
hassle head on over to rockauto.com
right now you can see all of the parts
available for your car or truck
they are available from hundreds of
manufacturers
you can check them all out same prices
for pros and do-it-yourselfers and then
most importantly
you can write knowles k-w-l-e-s in there
how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you rock auto
go head over to
rock auto today
white rage that's what general milly
wants to understand this is so pathetic
both
in the the conflation of critical
thinking
and critical theory they actually are
they're even
using the two terms interchangeably
critical thinking
would be when you use your faculties of
reason and apply
them to many problems critical theory is
a very specific lens it's an academic
ideology that seeks to debunk
everything dismantle everything bring it
all to criticize right the ruthless
criticism of all that exists to quote
karl marx who general milly seems to
like to read quite a lot
but but it's just so disingenuous to me
i i don't think that
millie is uh well he's maybe teaching
all of these stupid books
on robin d'angelo or ibram kennedy the
chief of naval operations michael gilday
defended the same sort of thing he said
that we need to have all of this
modern race hustling crap on the reading
lists in the various military academies
and for the the enlisted guys and the
ensigns and the sailors and everybody
else
but you think okay if you're if you're
reading all of that in
in the uh line of just sort of being
well read and understanding all the
problems if you if you want to
understand why
the hundreds according to millio it was
thousands of white
insurrectionists attacked the capital
and the coup d'etat okay fine
a little bit of a hyperbolic framing but
if you want to understand that
how come we don't also have books on the
reading list to understand
the blm terrorists who burned the
country down last year i don't
i don't see a whole lot of reading
focused on that problem
you see a lot of the the white rage well
what about the
black rage what about other kinds of
rage and frankly
what about the ideological lens because
the left is obviously framing this is a
racial thing
i strongly suspect that it's not
primarily a racial thing i strongly
suspect
it's ideological and these radicals are
hiding behind race
so where's that where's the leftist rage
where's that reading list i don't see it
wouldn't that make you a better red more
situationally aware military general
milly no because the
i mean it would but the arguments are
just total bunk it is just a way
of getting even the freaking top brass
at the pentagon
to defend this woke insanity
you've got the you've got the navy now
reading how to be an
anti-racist to to
better understand their country a book
that proposes quote future
discrimination
against white people that that is now on
the professional reading list so
this is very tricky the the arguments
they're making here because on the one
hand they are defending critical race
theory they're actually
going out you've got the cno you've got
the chairman and the joint chiefs
openly defending this radical leftist
ideology
and then when you call them on it a
little too hard they switch from
defending it
to denying that it even exists joy reid
pointed this out perfectly joy reid had
chris ruffo on
chris ruffo is the the manhattan
institute scholar
who has really popularized much of
what's going on
in critical race theory most people i
suspect had never heard this term
before chris ruffo made a big deal about
it so joy reid
invites him on her program and then
denies that critical race theory has any
effect on the world at all
well i'll say two things first of all
it's very interesting to me that so many
people are now
running away from the race of the the
the label of critical race theory
but he's not true hold on i'm going to
quote two critical race theorists
barbara applebaum with the book being
good being white she says quote
all white people are racist robin
deangelo who's another
critical whiteness study scholar
white identity is inherently racist so
what you're doing is you're playing a
series of word games
you know that critical whiteness studies
that is a subfield of critical race
theory no it's not these things are all
deeply interrelated
they're not and i'm not gonna let you
play word games and this is this is
really i think the most essential thing
hold on hold on no no no no let me
respond at least once i haven't gotten a
full sentence
because i'm i'm not gonna let you see
one of the things that i i know you
probably never watched me on tv just you
know we didn't know who each other were
you know not too long ago
but i don't allow people to just make up
and say lies on the show it's just not
really right to do that and let people
hear but hold on
am i right angelo is not a critical race
theorist and i want everyone to know
that robert
i don't know who the other woman is but
she's not okay i don't know who the
other woman i don't know anything really
about what you're saying here chris but
i just want you to know that
critical race theory is having no effect
whatsoever so this this is the absolute
gaslighting here and
it's worth watching this entire
15-minute painful
discussion i i can't even really call it
a discussion because joy reid wouldn't
like chris
get a word in edgewise but her argument
basically
is this retreat into nominalism
to use my friend matt peterson's phrase
over claremont there she's retreating
back into this point of well
what really is critical race theory no
it's not a big deal now
the left has has made a big deal out of
critical race theory for now going on
four decades
increasingly so but now that someone
actually called them out on it
all of a sudden they're denying it
exists and they'll play these little
semantic shifts
where you'll you'll place critical race
theory
in the broader tradition of critical
theory which is
a major topic of my book which is out
now for order speechless controlling
words and drawing moments thank you very
much to everyone who's ordered it
for those who are waiting and wondering
the bell is gone the book is out the
bell is gone
but i appreciate those of you who have
ordered it you get the audible audio
book and you can also get the
physical copy and i would recommend you
get both if you place
as conservatives are trying to do as
conservatives are trying to communicate
to people
crt within this broader history
that goes back to the frankfurt school
it goes back further to karl marx
and it goes forward into
intersectionality into as
chris mentioned their critical whiteness
studies which is what you're getting
at you know ethnic studies all of these
the broader school of grievance
school of resentment you you recognize
what a huge
influence this has all had on our
country it's not
merely that crt was invented
in 1981 or you know and flourish during
the 1980s at harvard law school and a
couple of other law schools
the the very point of crt is that you
can't limit it to just one academic
field
the thing has to branch out and pervade
things this is why martin j
who is a sympathetic scholar of critical
theory and he's probably one of the most
uh important ones that we've we've had
who actually gives the story of this
martin j says quoting other critical
theorists
the the genius of critical theory is
that it's not just its own academic
field
rather it is a gadfly on other academic
systems
which is why there's no critical theory
department
at most universities there is there are
literature departments
the ethnicity studies departments
history departments many other
departments
and critical theory has pervaded all of
them and certainly in law school through
crt
and certainly now in the broader culture
in the corporations in the media
and even in the military through this
woke race
hustling nonsense it permeates
everything according to our
national archives america was built
on structural racism so there was a
little noticed report
that came out from a national archives
task force on racism oh my gosh
does every institution now have a task
force on racism we're going to set up
the michael knowles show task force on
racism
and i guess we actually do that when we
point out the left's hypocrisy on race
but
no one takes those reports all that all
that much to heart
so the national archives which hosts
america's founding documents right the
constitution the declaration of
independence
uh says that the
uh there is structural racism that has
been
pres that has permeated american society
and the task force suggested major
changes
to how the constitution and other
records are presented
in order to provide quote context
how how on earth are they going to do
that i think it's pretty simple you've
got these documents that
laid the groundwork for our country but
we need to reframe
how they are presented right this is the
same kind of language that comes up in
the 1619 project
from nicole hannah jones it's the same
kind of language that you're getting
in the academic movements like crt and
it's the same sort of framing now that
you're getting throughout all of the
institutions
they believe that the founding fathers
and other white historically impactful
americans are portrayed too positively
and that's that's the issue when we're
we're talking it's not even so much the
facts you think about the 1619 project
it's based on a lie
the central thesis is that america was
founded to preserve slavery
that the the american revolution was
fought to preserve slavery it's just not
true
but the lie is almost incidental it's
almost a minor point compared to the
broader issue which is
as nicole hannah jones says openly we
want to reframe the history of the
country
to put slavery at the center of it i
will say this is a minor
pedantic point but but it does drive me
crazy when i whenever i see the word
impactful to me it's a red alert
because the word impactful is a very
very silly word some people defend it
but a thing cannot be full of impact and
it cannot fill with
impact it just isn't so i whenever i see
that
it's just a hint i'm not denying that
it's a word in the dictionary
i'm just saying it shouldn't be it's a
very silly word that people shouldn't
use
and it's just a hint to me that people
just are kind of mindlessly
using jargon it's like the sort of
people who use the word
synergy with a straight face it's just
it's these just these
words that enter into our
broader lexicon and when and people just
sort of repeat that and
i'm making sort of a joke about
impactful here but you see this with all
sorts of words like
structural racism beep boop beep beep
boop structure systemic
white supremacy patriarchy beep beep
beep no one knows what what these things
really mean
no one can quite put their hands on it
but they just they just repeat these
canards because that helps to uh
shape our mind and shape our culture so
the the task force by the way just
just for you trying to keep up says that
structural racism
in our founding documents includes quote
legacy
descriptions that use racial racial
slurs and harmful language to describe
bypoc communities by poc you're not
allowed to say
people of color anymore you now have to
say black and indigenous people of color
because other people of color don't
count
and also there are terrible terms you
can't use include
elderly you're not allowed to use that
term handicapped that's a terribly
bigoted term you're not allowed to do it
according to the national archives
and illegal alien which is as clinical a
term
as it gets you're not allowed to use
that presumably you have to use
terms like future american undocumented
american
imprecise terms that actually actually
mean the opposite of what they do
they purport to mean this term racism
is just a cudgel it's just
it's just a big hammer that the left
uses to smack their political opponents
without
any sense whatsoever and conservatives
are still afraid of it
we're we are still afraid of being
called racist it's the worst thing
you can be labeled as in this culture so
we're just
even if we know it's just it's not true
it's meaningless
we're still very afraid to do it uh
republican representative bob goode
was just criticizing critical race
theory which we are told
is both really really good and doesn't
exist right those are the simultaneous
arguments coming from the left and as
he's describing this on a house of
representative
conference call on just a zoom session
democrat rep
don norcross bereft of arguments unable
to
push back against what representative
good is saying
just randomly yells out racist
can you see this past week in virginia's
loudoun county one of the largest
counties in virginia
the board of education there rather than
face parental criticism
they shut down public comment they
adjourned the meeting and they actually
called the police to come in and arrest
parents who had gathered to express
their grievances with government and
local school officials
i i hope that you will not nationalize
the culture war that started in virginia
and
bankrupt critical race theory with hard
earned taxpayer dollars
racist right wow so brave so brave
representative norcross
gosh that really makes me think about
this subject in a new and fresh way
because you see but before i was just
trying to understand why these parents
are rising up
against critical race theory and its
various derivations in the schools and
what the motive but now you've explained
to me racist
wow gosh you know back
70 80 years ago in our in our rhetoric
in the west in the anglosphere you would
have phrases like we shall go on we
shall fight on the beaches and in the
streets we shall never
surrender you had the universe of
churchill's rhetoric but now we have the
beautiful rhetoric
of norcross and the democrats racist
you're a racist okay they can they can
demagogue all they want they can try to
get us to shut up about
crt and its related fields they can
defend it and they can deny it and they
can just try to muzzle us with that word
racist
but the fact is we're right about this
the parents recognize that the pair i
know that these elite politicians don't
believe that ordinary people ought to
have a say
in their children's education and in
their political communities but they
will and i don't care what general
milley
or the chief of naval operations or this
ridiculous democrat congressman or
anyone else has to say or joy reid or
anyone else
has to say about it because that the
theories the ideological frameworks
around crt and intersectionality and
wokeness and pc
it's all the same stuff are having a
huge effect
there was a u.s olympic
track and field trial on saturday
and one of the women athletes gwen berry
was a hammer thrower okay speaking of
speaking of using hammers to smack down
our opponents
gwen berry was there she placed third
there were two other athletes there in
the trials
and they begin playing the national
anthem so the the
two good patriotic athletes stood and
faced the flag with their hands on their
hearts
and this anti-american narcissist gwen
berry
turned to the side hand on her hip to
take a photo
she's probably auditioning to be the
next nike spokesman and she refused
to respect the flag
unfortunately i guess she's still going
to go to the tokyo olympics with the
united states now
if i were running the show i would not
permit that i would kick her off of the
team because she
obviously hates her country and
therefore we should not have her
representing
our country at the olympics i don't care
she may or
may not be a good athlete i i can't say
that i'm familiar with her
her accomplishments but i don't care if
she's the best athlete on the team
she hates her country so get off that
you don't have a right to be on the team
if you hate your country
it's a very basic thing the entire point
of the olympics
is to go and represent the best and the
strongest and the most wonderful of our
country and to put our country first
so the she begins to play she she then
wears a t-shirt that says
activist athlete she then tweets out a
picture of it
she says stop playing with me i wish we
would stop playing with this woman i
wish she would not play
on the american olympic team and then
she said my purpose and my mission is
bigger than sports i'm here to represent
those who died due to systemic racism
whatever that is that's the important
part that's that's why i'm going that's
why i'm here
today goodness gracious me
kick this gal off the team this is what
what worries me
if crt and intersectionality and
critical theory broadly
were just confined to a handful of
marxist cranks in the academy that would
be one thing
if it were as as joy reid pretends that
it is just confined to harvard law
school
that would be f fine it wouldn't it
wouldn't be good but harvard's kind of a
lost cause at this point
so we'll just we'll just let the the
institution rot
but the problem is it bleeds out i guess
at the heart of this denial that crt is
is broader than just one law school's
academic theory
is this denial of the belief that ideas
have consequences
a denial of the belief that when you
have an idea even if it begins in a law
school
that it then has effects throughout the
broader legal system throughout the
broader university system throughout the
broader culture and it obviously does
this theory that places white supremacy
and bigotry and
wickedness and evil at the heart of the
american story
that is having an effect on our olympic
team
and and therefore it's a problem
therefore this little academic theory
actually is a political problem for the
community and aoc
is coming out here and she's saying
ignore
ignore what you are seeing ignore
everything do not believe your lying
eyes because
you can draw direct correlation between
the insanity
that has been plaguing our universities
through things like crt
and crime in the streets you can draw a
direct line when
when uh charles kessler at the claremont
institute
called the 2020 summer of hate
called the blm riots the 1619 project
riots
and nicole hannah jones who who started
1619
said she was honored that she was proud
for them to be called the 1619 project
riots
she was proud that her
cultural and somewhat academic
pseudo-academic movement
was having real effects in the streets
she said that's great and that's
obviously what's
what's what is happening through crt and
through the other movements
they don't want to own up to it and now
ao is coming out and she's saying don't
believe your lying eyes
ben is going to be talking about the
effect of all of this on
the elections in 2022 ben seems to
believe that the democrats are in for a
real bruising in a couple years
i guess those elections the the
campaigns will really start next year
also do not forget about the clarence
thomas documentary created equal that
tells his story becoming a supreme court
justice
the movie did very very well with
audiences and then
it was removed from amazon isn't that so
strange during black history month of
all things
who knows why i can't imagine so get
your popcorn ready because now you can
stream create it equal any time it's
available
to daily wire members over at
dailywire.com once you're a member be
sure to check out all of our other great
content
like our talk show candace featuring
candace owens our first movie run hide
fight
invent shapiro's new series debunked
where ben debunks leftist myths in 15
seconds or less
15 seconds well it's supposed to be 15
minutes but knowing the way that ben
talks probably 15 seconds
you can get all of this and more on
demand by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
code justice
do not wait start streaming today and
while you're at it go pre-order
speechless i'm sorry go order order
speeches controlling words controlling
minds we're still in the top books on
amazon
they actually are right now i think
because the book is doing so well they
just
instituted a sale as of this moment
doing the show
the sale is still on it's like 36 off i
think that's only going to be going on
for
a day maybe two days so go pick up a
copy especially if you've been
checking out the audiobook it's nice to
be able to go back and forth thank you
to those who have ordered we'll be right
back with a lot more
there have been pretty big spikes in
crime around the country i'm thinking of
chicago where murders and shootings are
up 50 percent
i'm thinking of places like new york and
los angeles
where crime is clearly spiking before
our very eyes
but you know the left often believes
that you should not care about what's
going on in practice
when you could instead focus on what's
going on in theory
and in theory aoc believes everything is
fine
and this fear of crime going through the
roof well it's nothing more than
republican
hysteria we are seeing these headlines
about percentage increases
now i want to say that any amount of
harm is unacceptable
and too much but i also want to make
sure that this hysteria
you know that this doesn't drive a
hysteria and that we look at these
numbers in context
so that we can make responsible
decisions about what to allocate
um in that context you need to look at
the
murders going up 50 in context you know
what context lady
if this is going on on our streets we
want to get rid of it
and i i just don't think that this line
of argument is going to work for
democrats who are trying to win over
voters for 2022 and 2024
assuming that we can get our election
system back into order
assuming that we can get some of the
safeguards against fraud
back into order those safeguards were
taken away in large part
during the 2020 election and the excuse
was the coronavirus lockdowns
but now the democrats are trying to make
that permanent through a naked power
grab
and perversion of our electoral system
called hr1 and s1 thankfully it was shot
down for now we'll see how long that
lasts
so assuming you get all that in order
you're going to have to win over voters
and what what aoc is saying here
is you're being hysterical if you're
worried about your communities if you're
worried about the safety of your family
you're just being hysterical
come on this is bs this is just the
tricks and traps of white supremacy i
don't think so
i don't think it is not just race that
is causing people some some
problems it's not just this race
hustling there's also this
radical sexual politics there's a video
just came out from a spa
where a woman is going up to the manager
and complaining because
the spa has a transgender policy and the
spa allowed a dude
to go into the women's changing room and
just strip down
in front of the the women and
the the women don't want to have to see
this i don't think women and little
girls should be forced to see naked
grown men
with all of the various appendages and
the staff says sorry there's nothing we
can do he says he's a woman he's a woman
you know so it's okay i just want to be
clear with you
it's okay it's okay for a man to go into
the women's section
show his penis around the other women
young little girls under age
your spa we spa condone that is that
what you're saying
like i asked it so he could stay there
he could stay there what sexual
orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man he he's a man
he is a man he is not no female
he is not a female i love this woman
i love so what this woman is showing by
the way you can hear the way she's
speaking
is a little colloquial it's not
academic it's not fancy i suspect this
woman doesn't go
to sort of soirees at the the critical
race theory
organizations movement at harvard
college uh she doesn't sound like that
at all
she's speaking much more bluntly and
directly she also doesn't sound white
right we're told that the only people
who oppose these radical policies
are the white supremacists and whatever
this woman doesn't sound particularly
white to me
and she's going out there and she's
saying hey get that dude out of the
women's changing room
and the guy behind the counter says well
no you understand because of the sexual
orientation she says what about sexual
orientation i don't see sexual
orientation
i see a phallus okay that lets me know
he's a man
i love the you know you could probably
sit through about
10 hours of of sexuality studies women's
sex and gender studies
at harvard or yale or somewhere else and
and have them try to explain to you the
meaning of the deconstruction of the
gender and then this and
that and then this woman could go up
there and she'd say okay here's my
counterpoint
i see a phallus that's that's what lets
me know that he's a man
say you know gosh we could have saved
ourselves all that time all that jargon
to just know yes that is what lets you
know that he's a man and
it it's obviously wrong to force women
and little girls to change
to strip naked in front of dudes and to
have to see
naked dudes in their changing room
that's obviously wrong and no amount of
philosophizing by these kooks and cranks
on the campuses
is going to change that so you're seeing
this come up
especially at the school boards right
now but i bet you're going to see more
videos like this
as this crazy sexual politics continues
a pace
i think you're going to see women
finally push back and i don't think it's
going to be
the super duper elite white supremacist
whatever you know what the sort of
caricature of the people who run the
country
it's not going to be that it's going to
be
ordinary people of all sorts of races
with just even a
modicum of common sense it's not
not just what they tell us it is so chip
roy who's a congressman down in
in texas he is venting this frustration
this white rage i don't think it's just
white i think it's there is a bit of
rage going on
but i think it's rage in response to
the left's rage i think that the
indignation that conservatives feel
right now
is in response to say blm burning the
country down
both ideologically for many years but
also
literally last year i think it's in
response to our politicians
not serving the people on many important
issues
notably on immigration our country can't
enforce its most basic law it can't even
preserve its own borders as a country
and so chip roy down in texas is looking
at the situation he's saying
a lot of texans are wondering what what
the advantage is to us
to be in a union in the in this united
states
that won't do its most basic job and is
just leaving us
open to a surge of foreign nationals
pouring over every day
every state in the union should send
resources to the state of texas
to help us secure the border because
that government texas is going to secure
this border if the united states of
america is failing to uphold
its end of the bargain of our having a
union
and i've got people in texas that are
starting to rattle about what are we
getting out of this
uh equation what are we getting out of
being a part of a union
that won't secure its own border because
you know what it's our border too
as a texas state and we have a duty as a
state as a sovereign people to defend
ourselves this is pure
john locke kind of stuff the first gda
government to secure the
people and secure us and take care of
our communities
so what's the point what are we getting
out of i mean you are seeing
this fraying of the country and if there
is rage
on the part of conservatives it's
because we're watching this whole thing
collapse around us
we're watching now our olympic athletes
are not expected to salute the flag well
why not
because our other athletes in the nfl
are not saluting the flag
why they're actually protesting the flag
why why else because
our politicians now in the democratic
party are
disrespecting the flag and protesting
the flag and
encouraging the riots and the current
the sitting vice president of the united
states
was bailing out rioters during 2020 and
hillary clinton the
previous democratic nominee for
president was encouraging
civil unrest she said you can't you
can't be civil
with a political party that opposes what
you think what
that's an explicit call for for
political violence against
all of your opponents maxine waters the
same all of these guys
and so conservatives that not even just
conservatives ordinary people are
looking around and saying hold on
we're not conserving the border we're
not conserving
our traditions we're not conserving our
love of country we're not even
conserving the ladies changing room
what are you people doing what are you
doing and it's not just the democrats i
mean the democrats are the
or the problem here they're the ones who
are really
i think leading the charge to
disintegrate the country but the
republicans at the
at their very best are feckless the very
best they're doing nothing other than
occasionally
cutting taxes i like a tax cut
as much as the next guy but that ain't
gonna solve the problem
in on any serious issue
any meaningful cultural issue the
republicans have flopped they've caved
over the past
several decades so it's no wonder i i do
not advocate disintegration of the union
but it's no wonder that chip roy's
constituents are telling him hey what
what are we getting out of this it seems
like all we're doing is give give give
and we're not we're not getting anything
out of this union i think
probably a lot of ordinary americans are
feeling that way
speaking of the southern border by the
way you now have
you now have president joe biden poor
old joe biden just trying to keep up
with the
political prevailing winds he is now
embraced the term
latinx you know la tinx this is the new
term
originally about four or five decades
ago
you had mexicans and guatemalans and
salvadorans and
hondurans and nicaraguans you had people
from the
latino world from from latin america
had their own distinct nationalities
then
through the machinations in no small
part of groups like the ford foundation
of leftist groups that that saw the
success of the black civil rights
movement
and wanted to model different racial
solidarity progressive movements
after that they created this idea of the
hispanic then hispanic became latino but
latino you see is not very
intersectional because the
o implies that the the man has a special
role here right latino is masculine
but it can't just be latina so they made
it latinx which is not a spanish word
at all in spanish of course is a
european language
that came over when christopher columbus
invented hispanic people
by landing on the shores so all of that
to say
quite complicated representative carlos
jimenez
is a latinx representative
he's a republican in florida and he just
eviscerated president biden for using
this silly term that has
that has no significance in his own
community
can i ask you as a fellow hispanic
american
what your thoughts are on the fact that
i i found it really demeaning frankly
that uh that comment there that you know
all hispanics are afraid of being
deported
i also don't like the term latinx i
don't even know what the heck it means
to be quite honest
what are your thoughts on that i i
didn't even know what that
meant either so if i don't i don't know
i i
really don't know look i'm uh i'm
hispanic i'm a legal immigrant i'm a
citizen of the united states i'm a us
congressman
um and so you know uh we
we are just like everybody else we came
here
uh looking for a a better life
my father my mother brought me here
looking for a better life
escaping socialism and communism in cuba
uh and we're really proud to be uh
americans
and and so that somehow we're different
than anybody else and that we're gonna
we're afraid we're going to be deported
uh no uh
that's not the case and so you know i
think i think the president really is
out of touch
he's obviously out of touch he goes on
to say
that there is there is a racist
undertone to the implication that
latinos are all
undocumented that they're all illegal
aliens obviously many came here
legally and and la tinx he says is the
stupid
stupidest thing he's ever heard of uh
which is quote insulting to our culture
to try and restructure an entire
language
to fit your politics yes keep your
wokeness out of our language he says but
the thing is wokeness and language are
the same thing
the the perversion of language
is the primary vehicle of wokeness it's
the primary
instrument by which wokeness advances
which coincidentally is the topic of my
book speechless which many of you are
reading right now and i appreciate and
those of you who haven't ordered it yet
you can order it and then you'll know
exactly what the congressman is talking
about
a lot of people just want to speak
freely this is what
so many on the right but also
kind of in the middle and also
disaffected liberals are saying and i'm
thinking in particular
about winston martial who's a musician
from the band mumford and sons
i really like mumford and sons actually
i don't listen to a lot of contemporary
music but i've always enjoyed mumford
and sons
and you might remember a few months ago
winston marshall committed the
unforgivable sin of reading andy knows
book about antifa
and having enjoyed it so he said oh i
liked i liked this book
this got him canceled and at the time
winston attempted to placate the mob and
i thought this was a big mistake
he tried to say hey look i'm learning
and i'm sorry and please don't
please take me back take me back and i
at the time
i thought of the final one of the final
scenes of breaking bad
when when hank the cop brother-in-law's
lying on the ground the gangster
standing over him with a gun about to
shoot him
and and walter you know uh brian
granson's character says
just apologize just say it's okay just
say you want to arrest him and hank
turns to me says oh my gosh
you're the smartest guy i know but
you're too stupid to realize he made up
his mind to kill me 10 minutes ago
that's just like the mob and so they did
not accept his apology
they continued to cancel him he's just
announced he's leaving mumford and sons
to speak freely
i think we got to know this is the way
it's always going to work out the choice
is not between
being cancelled or being uncanceled the
choices between when that mob
can't comes for you keeping your dignity
or losing
your dignity
freedom requires limits it's as simple
as that i think this is the biggest
lesson that people are learning right
now you're seeing it in the arguments
over the curriculum
in various schools and over critical
race theory and over transgenderism and
all of this stuff
there was a japanese soccer player kumi
yokoyama she's a soccer player on the
japanese women's national team as well
as on the washington spirit which is
apparently an american soccer team
and kumi yokoyama has come out and said
that she is transgender
and she posted a video about this it's
in japanese so we're not going to play
it
my japanese is a little rusty but she
came out and said that she is trans she
previously said she was a lesbian now
she's transgender which i guess makes
her a straight man
i'm i'm not particularly interested in
these soccer teams and i don't
know anything about this woman but if
she is now transgender if she is now
saying that she is a man
my simple question is this is she going
to be kicked off the team
because she's a she's on a women's team
right but now she says she's a man but
no one's
asking if she's going to be kicked off
of the team now
presumably she will not even though
she's
according to the logic of transgenderism
she is 100 fully a man now
she should not be allowed to play on the
team but what this really gets to
is there
are always limits to speech to behavior
to freedom to the natural world
when this leftist year's tumblr is a
tumblr it's not
a book this is a book and this is a
tumblr it's not when a thing
is defined right when a thing is a thing
it is not
other things it is not thing let me try
to bring this down to earth a little bit
more i guess we talk about this in the
classroom
if two plus two equals four then two
plus two does not equal five and
you have to kick the idea that two plus
two equals five out of the university
you need to you need to ban it from the
classroom and if someone says the two
plus two equals five you need to punish
that person with a bad grade
now this is illiberal and authoritarian
some people would suggest it's not it's
acknowledging
that if a man is a man he is necessarily
not a woman
and by the way i'm even granting the
illogic of transgenderism here i'm even
saying
that a man can become a woman let's just
say let's just go with that
if he becomes a woman then he's
necessarily not a man
and is not not permitted to be on the
team if that team
is a single sex team you you have to
make distinctions this is the whole
process of language
is distinguishing one thing from another
and so it's obviously going to be
exclusive you can't just
live and let live hey man we'll just
let's just be cool and tolerate
everything i mean this is the
the great genius of someone like herbert
marcuza one of the most influential
critical theorists
father of the new left who's who says in
that infamous essay repressive tolerance
that you can't tolerate intolerance and
and all the conservatives went after him
for it he was right
he was totally right you you can't
tolerate intolerance
you can't that that would be
self-undermining and so you've got
you've got to make these distinctions
you've got to take on certain ideas
you've got to kick other ideas out
now speaking of just limits we are now
seeing voter laws around the country
notably in georgia to try to reinstate
the election integrity measures that we
had until last year
and the federal government doesn't like
this the biden administration
the attorney general merrick garland
they do not like this idea so they're
going to sue
georgia for trying to protect their
election system
today the department of justice is suing
the state of georgia
our complaint alleges that recent
changes to georgia's election laws
were enacted with the purpose of denying
or bridging the right of black georgians
to vote on account of their race or
color in violation of section 2
of the voting rights act
several studies show that georgia
experienced record voter turnout and
participation rates
in the 2020 election cycle approximately
two-thirds of eligible voters in the
state cast a ballot
in the november election just over the
national average
this is cause for celebration
but then in march of 2021 georgia's
legislature passed sb
202 many of that law's provisions make
it harder
for people to vote the complaint alleges
that the state enacted those
restrictions
with the purpose of denying or abridging
the right to vote
on account of race or color so i want to
give merrick garland credit here
he's right the georgia law does make it
harder for certain people to vote
makes it harder for dead people to vote
makes it harder for people who don't
live in georgia to vote
makes it harder for political operatives
to vote on behalf of other people who
are it does it actually does limit the
vote
to only the people who ought to be
voting it's not about
race or sex or this or that it's about
the integrity of the election system
this is a naked power grab here by the
federal government and by the way do you
want to know the proof
that the federal government knows that
these laws are intended
to beef up election integrity
they are admitting in their own federal
election paragraphs here you've got the
the doj going in and trying to fix this
through lawsuits
but the congress is also trying to do it
through the corrupt politicians act hr
one and s1
and there they admit in the law
that their proposed changes
are going to register a lot of
ineligible voters to vote the reason for
this is
they give immunity to illegal aliens
who vote illegally they give legal
immunity to them
so what the law first does is it
registers a ton of illegal aliens
then the democrats deny that the illegal
aliens are being registered
but then the democrats put in a special
provision saying that when the illegal
aliens inevitably vote
it to some degree they're going to
receive legal immunity
okay they know that when you get rid of
when you have widespread mail-in ballots
that even obama admits is susceptible to
fraud
when you have election day turn into
election season
when you have automatic voter
registration when you have
unsecured ballot drop boxes when you
have all these things then the problem
of voter fraud which exists in every
election to begin with
is going to get much worse and so
they're trying to actually defend
against that and merrick garland is now
doubling down on that
that is his that is his hope by the way
before we go
wajahat ali he's a leftist blue check
and journalist
he just tweeted out he said i feel
america's forgotten we're in the middle
of a
pandemic that's killed more than 600
thousand people there's a deadly delta
plus strain
and our kids are still not vaccinated
sigh i see packed restaurants and people
inside stores and malls
and their kids aren't wearing masks i
feel like i'm in a horror movie i feel
like i'm in a horror movie
you have the left in this country
looking around at just
ordinary life ordinary normal country
going around without muzzles on your
face all the time
and they view that as a horror movie
they're viewing they're viewing our
traditional way of life
as an absolute [ __ ] and they're trying
to undo it and it's why i think you're
seeing
just a touch of rage across all
demographic groups it's just a touch of
rage
on the other side because they don't
they don't view our country
as we do not view our country as a
horror movie we want to preserve
something
the only horror we see are the people
trying to upend the entire culture i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt well show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show